mehr geld für beschäftigte im
öffentlichen dienst arbeitgeber und
gewerkschaften einigen sich im
tarifstreit krisensitzung in der
cdu-zentrale die partei streitet wann
und wie der neue vorsitzende bestimmt
werden soll
verstöße gegen korona regeln die polizei
löst partys auf mehrere kommunen
verschärfen wegen steigender zahlen ihre
maßnahmen
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen am sonntag bei den
nachrichten sport gibt es auch heute mit
christian otto sehr gerne guten abend
wie viel ist der gesellschaft die arbeit
von pflegekräften wird schwierige frage
in pandemie zeiten denn einerseits
sollen sie gerade wegen der
mehrbelastung profitieren andererseits
ist aufgrund von corona die kassenlage
angespannt doch bund und kommunen haben
mit den gewerkschaften einen kompromiss
gefunden für die frauen und männer die
im öffentlichen dienst arbeiten
insgesamt gibt es 3,2 prozent mehr geld
laufzeit 28 monate zum ersten april 2021
steigen löhne und gehälter um 1,4
prozent mindestens aber um 50 euro ein
jahr darauf um weitere 1,8 prozent jan
meyer berichtet erst in der vergangenen
nacht gelang der durchbruch am mittag
unterzeichneten die tarifpartner in
potsdam dann einen kompromiss mit dem
die besondere leistungen des
öffentlichen dienstes in den vergangenen
monaten gewürdigt werden sollen alle
beschäftigten erhalten eine corona
sonderprämie 600 euro gehen an die
unteren lohngruppen 400 an die mittleren
und 300 an die oberen entgeltgruppen
das ist eine differenzierung die wir uns
gewünscht haben weil in dieser
schwierigen zeit ist uns wichtig war
dass insbesondere für die unteren und
mittleren einkommen es zu einer erhöhung
kommt die angestellten der kommunalen
krankenhäuser und pflegeeinrichtungen
erhalten künftig monatlich eine zulage
von 70 euro die ab 2022 um weitere 50
euro angehoben wird
die tariferhöhungen für die
beschäftigten von bund und kommunen
belasten die öffentlichen haushalte mit
fast 5 milliarden euro
die eckpunkte für diesen tarifvertrag
erfolgen in einer sehr schwierigen zeit
in einer pandemie die unsere bevölkerung
und das ganze land sehr bewegt wir
bewegen uns mit diesen tarifvertrag aus
der sicht der öffentlichen arbeitgeber
an der grenze des finanziell verkraftbar
die verhandlungspartner in potsdam haben
nicht alle erwartungen erfüllt besonders
techniker ingenieure und sparkassen
mitarbeiter profitieren weniger als
erhofft
in der cdu tobt gerade ein streit und
zwar über die frage ob der für dezember
geplante parteitag wegen corona
verschoben werden sollte
immerhin soll da der neue vorsitzende
bestimmt werden am nachmittag kamen
deswegen die ängste cdu-spitze in berlin
zusammen
einer der drei kandidaten armin laschet
ist für verschieben
sein konkurrent friedrich merz besteht
dagegen auf der wahl noch in diesem jahr
morgen soll sich definitiv entscheiden
wann und wie gewählt wird er theo koll
geht es hier nur um den zeitpunkt oder
steckt mehr dahinter
naja wie so oft in berlin hat auch diese
frage eine zweite ebene vordergründig
geht es natürlich darum kann die cdu in
diesen zeiten ein parteitag abhalten bei
dem sich 1000 und ein delegierter aus
ganz deutschland treffen um den neuen
parteichef zu wählen also kann sich die
politik in einer wichtigen frage etwas
erlauben was man dem bürger untersagt
selbst bei besten gene konzentrieren
sich die frage wem nutzt oder schadet
möglicherweise eine verschiebung
friedrich merz ist momentan in den cdu
internen umfragen weit vorn er sucht
deshalb eine frühe entscheidung eine
verschiebung könnte seinen vorsprung
riskieren
armin laschet dagegen hätte die chance
sich über den winter als corona
krisenmanager zu profilieren und in den
umfragen nach oben zu gehen und wenn man
darüber hinaus an die kanzlerkandidatur
denkt dann stärkt eine späte cdu
entscheidung auch den einfluss des csu
chefs der ja als erster übrigens
empfohlen hatte den parteitag zu
verschieben hintergründe von theo koll
danke dafür nach berlin
mithelfen konsequenz sein
zusammen halten dazu hat jens spahn
heute aufgerufen aus der häuslichen
quarantäne heraus der
bundesgesundheitsminister ist ja selbst
infiziert mit corona laut robert koch
institut gab es 11.000 176 neue
infektionen in 24 stunden an sonntagen
sind die zahlen meist niedriger unter
anderem weil die gesundheitsämter an den
wochenenden nicht alle daten übermitteln
über die aktuelle virus lage in
deutschland berichtet thomas ganze
partie in der pandemie
rund 600 gäste haben hier gefeiert
mitten in berlin mitten in der zweiten
corona welle die kleidung spärlich der
abstand auch polizei löst das treiben
auf bitte mehr rücksicht so eine
botschaft kommt auch von einem
infizierten aus der quarantäne
mir geht es soweit in umständen
entsprechend ganz gut bitte helfen sie
weiter mit
und hören sie nicht auf diejenigen die
verharmlosen und beschwichtigen
es ist ernst wie ernst zeigt sich etwa
in frankfurt mehr als 200 infizierte pro
100.000 einwohner folgen verschärfte
masken pflicht einen herbstmarkt gibt es
noch der weihnachtsmarkt ist abgesagt im
ernstfall noch mehr schließen auch diese
forderungen mit laut müssten wir
tatsächlich wieder in einen lock down
zurückgehen
also laden wieder zu das leben noch mal
stark herunterfahren
was ich schade finden würde ich das man
vielleicht familienfeiern dann auch
schon einschränken muss wenn man auch
die älteren generationen dann treffen
mit obama dafür sich sage ich jetzt mal
die zahlen noch weiter erhöhen oder eben
auch schlimmer werden denke ich in
locktow immer noch besser als es
irgendwie nach sich verschlimmert ihnen
gehen die korona maßnahmen jetzt schon
viel zu weit hunderte bei protesten mehr
menschen als masken mitten in berlin
mitten in der pandemie
wie schon im frühjahr hat das virus
spanien und italien wieder voll im griff
in madrid hat die regierung deswegen
erneut den nationalen notstand
ausgerufen und mindestens für die
nächsten zwei wochen eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre
in italien müssen restaurants und bars
bereits um 18 uhr schließen kinos
theater oder fitnessstudios dürfen gar
nicht erst öffnen den elften sonntag in
folge gab es massenproteste in belarus
mehr als hunderttausend menschen gingen
auf die straße und das trotz massiver
polizei und militär präsenz
sicherheitskräfte schossen mit
blendgranaten laut einer
menschenrechtsorganisation gab es rund
100 festnahmen
die opposition hatte präsident
lukaschenko bis heute ein ultimatum
gestellt
sie fordert unter anderem seinen
rücktritt und neuwahlen
für morgen hat sie zu einem landesweiten
generalstreik aufgerufen
in chile ist dieser sonntag für viele
ein tag der hoffnung bürger und
bürgerinnen stimmen darüber ab ob irland
eine neue verfassung bekommt etwa 14
millionen chilenen sind wahlberechtigt
die aktuelle verfassung stammt noch aus
der zeit der pilot militärdiktatur der
konservative präsident pinera hatte dem
referendum zugestimmt nachdem es seit
dem vergangenen jahr heftigen
massenproteste gegeben hatte
mit mindestens 30 toten von che lena
hannover dort ist der umweltpreis der
deutschen bundesstiftung umwelt
verliehen worden
er ging zu gleichen teilen an den
direktor vom potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung ottmar edenhofer
und an die geschwister trappmann sie
hätten in ihrer blechwarenfabrik
vorbildliche maßnahmen zum klimaschutz
eingeführt so die begründung der preis
ist mit 500.000 euro dotiert und nun zum
sport am sonntag mit kristin hab gleich
mal ein rekord formel-1-weltmeister
lewis hamilton gewinnt den großen preis
von portugal und verbucht seinen 92
riesig einen mehr als michael schumacher
der bisher die bestmarke hielt für den
briten die erfüllung eines weiteren
traum
92 mal ganz oben auf dem podest lewis
hamilton schreibt sportgeschichte
überholt michael schumacher dessen
rekord einst als eine für die ewigkeit
galt hamilton verteidigt beim start
seine pole position
aber regen setzt ein wirbelt das feld
gehörig durcheinander
carlos sainz übernimmt noch in der
ersten runde die führung bald sind die
üblichen machtverhältnisse mit einer
doppelführung für mercedes wieder
hergestellt in runde 20 überholt
hamilton den teamkollegen waters gewinnt
vor ihm und marx fest hatten hamilton
auf dem weg zum siebten em titel kaum
noch zu bremsen würde damit mit
schumacher gleich sebastian vettel mit
53,7 dritter der ewigen bestenliste
startet als fünfzehnter rettete am ende
auf platz 10 einen wm-punkt und zum
fußball ein doppelschlag binnen 82
sekunden und der erste saisonsieg ist
geglückt 2 2 1 gewinnt der vfl wolfsburg
im ersten sonntagsspiel gegen aufsteiger
arminia bielefeld wegen eines corona
falls haben die engländerinnen das
länderspiel gegen die deutschen
fußballerinnen am dienstag in wiesbaden
abgesagt einen nachholtermin gibt es
nicht die partie war als highlight
anlässlich 50 jahre frauenfußball in
deutschland geplant tennisprofi
alexander zverev teilt innerhalb einer
woche sein zweiten turnier erfolg an
wie schon am vergangenen sonntag steht
erneut in köln im finale nach einem
zweisatzerfolg 7 zu 6 und 6 3 gegen den
19 jahre alten janicke sinne der ihn
erst kürzlich bei den french open
besiegt hatte es wäre es endspielgegner
am abend yego schwarzmann aus
argentinien und in 20 minuten gehts los
danke christin und was macht das wetter
im augen von der ostsee bis zu den alpen
teils kräftiger regen im westen
weitgehend trocken und einige
auflockerungen
höchstwerte 8 bis 16 grad das war es für
den moment mehr gibt es im heute journal
mit christian sievers um viertel vor
zehn
er hat fragen an friedrich merz und wir
melden uns morgen wieder zur stelle um
19 uhr